my favorite activity in Haiti was simply
walking the streets and meeting the
people hey this is John Luke he lives
here in port-au-prince he says he
watches me every single night that is so
fantastic and you say that you you think
you know you can do is fist ring dances
at it yeah I forgot about that
hey everybody this is Schneider you're
from port-au-prince and I gotta say
you've got some great style going on
here yeah I like the glasses I like the
the belt you got it all going on yeah
I'm a modest Oh do you think I could be
a male model
[Music]
good okay oh she's holding it V
President Trump insulting Haiti so I
thought it was only fair to give
Haitians a chance to return the favor
top we envy society must be shocked
wahoo PPP you silly aside thousand
involved appeal Delta Gamma Sigma Z doc
bin Jia me us even your PE democracy it
doesn't leave em Sebastian
to the Guardian University Auckland area
where food hurry hurry men I will play
Belding law for immigration reform
issues issue
if the spit of on Philemon you live here
in port-au-prince right yes I do
okay now you know that this is the
famous hat already
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes very good overtime
my plate home
[Applause]
you